hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start
warning
spoilers ahead
today
i'm gonna explain a 2020 polar social
thriller and award-winning movie
called the hater
this is a film that captures the big
horrifying consequences of social media
influence in real life
done by a seemingly ordinary student the
movie begins with tomek or tomas giemza
a law student who was dropped out of
college due to committing plagiarism but
managed to get his professor's signature
on his book later in the evening he
attended a dinner with the krasuki's a
wealthy upper-class family who is also a
scholarship grantor the parents robert
and zocia seem impressed with tameck
mugabe the daughter acts coldly even
though she knows she will be attending
the same university as him tamek
purposely leaves his phone in a kasuki
residence to eavesdrop on the family
conversation after he leaves in which he
found out that zosia plans to grant him
more money and gabi comments bitterly
about him tamik moves out of his student
dorm despite his friends not being
convinced he can afford to rent he
applies for jobs related to marketing
and social media but does not seem to
get any offers on one evening he joins
his friends to a club finds gabi there
and dances with her before she suddenly
resents him again he eavesdrops on a
middle aged woman on a phone call
seemingly furious with the person on the
other end saying that they do not know
how a millennial does it tomek takes his
chance to talk to the woman biata
santorska who works at bezba's public
relations agency and convinces her that
he can do the job even for free
biata promises to send him the brief by
email then leaves then tomic finds gobby
very drunk and walks her home safely
later that evening tomic receives a
letter containing the brief from briata
he is asked to reduce the public
popularity of a fitness influencer fit
anita
he finds out that the influencer has
been promoting a new juice diet that
contains turmeric and aspires to create
a false campaign promoting bad effects
of the tumeric juice while presenting to
biata and her trusted co-worker camille
tommen gets questioned about the ethical
issues of his idea but he cleverly
counters biata's statement saying that
both of them are not interested in real
ethical marketing he gets the job but
just as he starts working camille asks
him to urgently find weak points of a
politician campaigning to be the next
mayor of warsaw
powell rudniki
tomek is startled when web search
results show connection between rodniki
and the krasuki family but he claims to
camille that he has not found any weak
points yet gabi invites tomic to her
sister's birthday natalia they sneak out
and play truth or dare in a darkened
room where he learns that she has been
struggling with depression issues and
started therapy
he also admits to her that he dropped
out of college which leaves her very
puzzled they are interrupted by robert
justice tomic is about to explain to
gabi that he plans to tell the truth to
her parents and return all the
scholarship money after that he does not
hear any word from gabi even unfriended
by her on social media on the other hand
his false campaign on fit anita works
wonderfully as the influencer is forced
to suspend her activity and publishes an
apology video to which satisfies biata
very much biater promises him a bonus
and orders him to learn about more
advanced equipment such as micro cameras
and wire tapes to sabotage people's
conversations and make his job easier
but riskier gabi still does not respond
to atomic social media messages so he
decides to come to a charity auction
organized by the krasuki's it turns out
that robert and zosia already knew the
truth about him but he still promises to
return the money at the same event he
finds out that rodniki is there as an
honored guest he comes to the krasuki
residence when the family is not at home
places sabotaging devices on gabi's
bedroom and places all his scholarship
money on her bed at work he gets a new
assignment to bring now rodniki's
popularity so he conducts deep research
and carefully listens to the krasuki
family conversations from his sabotaging
devices he's surprised when finding out
that gabi is dating stasek a good man
closely related to the krasuki's his
social media campaigns against roniki by
using many fake accounts have not shown
any good results
one day tomek meets his former college
roommate marcin at a shooting arena
asking to teach him how to shoot he
closely observes the arena the staff and
the security system after the session he
hangs out with marcin and his friends at
a bar in which he learns from their
conversation that the group shows no
interest in rodniki's campaign even
seeming to dismiss him a guy named guzek
shows up which marcin's friend refer as
someone doing nonsense actions trying to
be viral on the internet including
stacking explosive in his basement
however they acknowledge him to be a
good shooter tomic finds out more about
guzek on social media and discovers that
he frequently posts videos on the
internet tomek comes to stazak's art
exhibition venue to meet zosia and
directly apologizes for his actions he
also expresses his intention to
volunteer in the upcoming art exhibition
in which zosia agrees but warns him not
to use the chance to approach gabi again
he continues to stalk guzak and arranges
to meet his character in his favorite
video game he narrates how european
fundamental values are threatened by
external forces and the elites cannot
save them and demands guzik's service to
resist the fall of europe at the art
exhibition zosia introduces tamik to
rodniki in which roniki invites tomic to
join his campaign team but he
reluctantly dismisses during the press
conference of the exhibition guzek
verbally attacks rodniki accuses him
being a communist and briefly disrupts
the event before being dragged out by
the security the moment goes viral on
the internet to which biata praises but
her secret client demands more exposing
a social scandal of roniki tomek notices
the secret client uses strange words in
the brief
he applies to raniki's campaign team to
get closer to him much to rodney is
surprised of his change of mind he
discovers an old news showing roniki
might support lgbt rights which inspires
him to take rudnicki for a dinner drunks
him and invites him to a gay club where
he insists roniki to dance with him the
footage of rudniki in the club causes
social media chaos in which biata is
happy for but drives raniki completely
stressed out tamak convinces rodniki to
make a public statement so his
supporters are not disappointed from his
sabotaging devices in the krasuki
residence he learns that the family
plans to invite him to an opera which
she awkwardly attends and gabi is moving
to new york with stasek he hacks into
camille's devices and creates a long
march of them for both roniki supporters
and opposers people are joining the
event even the krasuki family tamek
meets again with guzek in the video game
to give him the next mission but guzek
shows doubt the long march event results
in a little clash but does not seem to
negatively affect rodniki's reputation
on the way home tomek proposes a panel
event for nikki and his important
supporters to which the krasuki's agree
he then asks guzak for another mission
maguzik is reluctant on the risk of the
mission and demands a lot of money while
tomek figures out how to execute his
next mission he listens to rodniki's
interviews on the internet he suddenly
notices familiar strange words said by
rodniki's competitor marcie zosda and
deduces that zozda is his secret crying
all along he comes to zazda admits that
he works for him and asks for a lot of
money to ensure the secrecy of his work
zazda agrees but when tomek reports to
guzak guzek demands a higher amount at
work biata and camille seem to
disapprove of tomek's actions even
camille kicks tomic out of his room and
orders him to moderate the contents
again
tomek approaches biata and cleverly
asked her to give him the money he
needed in which biata agrees to do but
dismisses him afterwards tomek can
finally execute his plan he breaks into
the shooting arena steals a gun and
transfers it to guzak he gives one last
brief to guzek in the video game before
he asks guzak to kill his character
ensuring all gooza's demands are met but
they cannot see each other in real life
surprisingly he finds gabi in the panel
event to which she explains that she
wants to directly apologize to him and
he did not deserve the things she had
done to him he's startled by gabi's
presence when he realizes his plan is
now in motion the panel is interrupted
by a mass shooting done by a mass guzak
guzek successfully kills natalya runiki
and several other people before tomek
performs a heroic act to stab him but
unfortunately he also gets stabbed in
the process and passes out tomek is
regarded as a hero for helping stop
guzak with the whole social media
praising and congratulating him while
still recovering in a hospital he
receives visitors from the country's
anti-terrorism agency who deduces that
guzek might have an accomplice when
carrying out his mission when questioned
about his possibility of involvement in
the case he performs a desperate cry
saying the government agents have no
empathy for him after all he had been
through after being sent out from the
hospital he gains control of the best
buzz pr agency after blackmailing biata
that he has evidence of her crime and
kicks camille out of the firm in the
last scene tomic is shown attending a
dinner at the krasuki's again this time
the whole family acknowledges him
silently even gabi gratefully accepts
him
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching